it'll wind welcome to this video playing
Pandora's box the numbering is right and
let's get rolling hmm what is the box
thinking about yep thanks for the kind
words if you you can see the first
couple of words there is this somehow
obscured don't know why you just thank
you for doing the channel and so on okay
place them the center Center
Game Center Cambodia essentially this is
an incorrect opening but you have to
know how and why and everything and I
don't know how and why I think you can
just take you for it and be better but
even this is good I think everything is
good you have it I don't know the
details is the thing
I don't really know I think they go a
three now what we should be three why is
the text obscured in the first place
anyway um okay then now just to go back
let's put put pawns in the center
classical blame
yeah I don't really believe that he can
give away that you for born like that
but the position the whole this whole
opening is notoriously murky it's just
oftentimes some completely irritating
it's not hard to believe that there
should be enough I could have played d4
as well trading the dark squared bishop
sir would be helpful it would increase
my stability on the dark squares a lot
when there is no pin on g5 and so on d4
was possible even though it's not clear
that I'm threatening that much why is
this obscured the text is set
it's odd okay
returns to e to a good d4 they were
probably yeah I probably will play
Bishop h6 something like that so if I
just continue to develop like here
Bishop f5 it can hardly be bad better
developed one idea is simply if I go
deform and he calls Bishop before I can
take with the bishop as well it's
probably not so relevant d4 he will play
Bishop age six most likely
that attacks both bishops
and if I take C 3 Bishop takes is
attacking ie 5 and 2 Bishop f5 maybe was
their blundering a piece here don't
don't give me that
like I mean why play is a complete
catastrophe of an opening like
completely completely incorrect and then
I'm blundering here la we really have to
do this
a bishop f5 head wrong already
it felt wrong tomorrow okay I go defy
you will probably take on f5 I take c3
Bishop takes 27 something like that it's
not not what I wanted but that's
probably what I'll get there is no way
to give up the Queen I guess I have to
go through several and now why does
probably equal like if it takes
everything only five you can maybe
try to hide for draw
I'm still a bit better due to the
activity and now he gives me this wrong
which I'm taking don't see why not
mmm okay not entirely certain what's the
best way is here red cheek maybe taking
is best and then put this on e5 ride
upon a g5 is extremely weak just wonder
how do I use it
this is probably how
too many pawns
yeah too many points don't need to allow
the weakening of the spawn structure
really
okay
run run Forrest run and it is actually F
pawn so Forrest actually works okay so
let's have a look Bishop f5 force
extremely stupid really yeah here if I'm
not mistaken Knight takes e4 is just
possible this whole line has a
reputation of being pretty refuted for
engine wants to play Knight takes e4 I
think this is also good but I don't I
don't remember f3 I mean F 3 cannot be
critical I think they do this and then
Bishop d6 f4 I think this is how they
play it but it's not enough fulfillment
for what would be would be reiative it
is so f 3 was played went back and I
mean I'm just a grown up
Bishop f5 was probably quite stupid yeah
divorce is certainly not bad but yeah
and now I have to allow this which is
fun yeah by far not enough if you look
at what I had before him I'm a little
bit better organized but it is not a
real advantage and this is not just
clear to me and this is just a big pond
miss something here I take Taguchi - of
course - I wasn't complete technical a
moment
it does it does win I mean I have no
reason us and that helps a lot yeah if
you have no pawn weakness that the
opponent can attack I think after that
it was a reasonably simple technical
task and I don't think I made any big
mistake okay guys thanks for watching